madame le
[Musique]
président
la séance est reprise nous reprenons la
discussion de la proposition de loi
relative aux outils de lutte contre la
désertification médicale des
collectivités présentées par Monsieur
Dany watteublé et plusieurs de ses
collègues
dans la discussion générale nous sommes
parvenus à l'intervention de Madame
Véronique Guillotin pour le groupe RDSE
pour 5 minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la Présidente de commission je
vois pas monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues les occasions de parler des
giférés sur notre système de santé ont
été nombreux ces dernières années et
pour cause nous héritons aujourd'hui
d'un système de soins dégradés après 40
années de politique publique qui n'ont
pas été à la hauteur des enjeux et qui
n'ont pas su anticiper les
transformations de notre société la
baisse du nombre de médecins provoquer
par un humérus clausus beaucoup trop
contraint à des fins avoués de
régulation de dépenses de santé nous ont
conduit à la pénurie actuelle en même
temps le vieillissement de la population
ainsi que l'augmentation de la
prévalence des maladies chroniques ont
aggravé la situation et aujourd'hui 72%
de la population vit dans une zone à
offre de soins insuffisante soit 48
millions de français malgré le numerus
apertus les difficultés vont perdurer
plusieurs années encore avec de nombreux
départs en retraite non remplacés la
nouvelle génération souhaite mieux
concilier vie personnelle et vie
professionnelle et c'est légitime il
faut transformé de voir trois
généralistes pour remplacer celui qui
part cette réalité a naturellement
engendrée de nombreuses initiatives
parlementaires je suis souvent sceptique
sur l'empilement des textes visant à
résoudre la question de la
désertification médicale je suis surtout
convaincue que les tentatives nombreuses
et répétées de renforcer les obligations
des professionnels ne réconcilieront pas
les jeunes avec l'exercice de ce métier
devenu peu attractif même si dans le
contexte les tentations sont grandes
cette proposition de loi vient toutefois
porter un nouvel outil qui tranche avec
une logique de coercition et de logique
financière tout en permettant de dégager
du temps médical elle vise à autoriser
la mise à disposition de fonctionnaires
dans les cabinets médicaux et les
maisons de santé en zone soudance les
agents des trois fonctions publiques si
l'amendement du Gouvernement est adopté
pourrait ainsi
permettre à aux agents d'effectuer des
missions de secrétariat gérer l'accueil
des patients et réaliser une partie du
travail administratif pour un jeune qui
s'installe à voir au départ à ses côtés
une personne de confiance qui connaît le
territoire pour y être incitatif et
l'aider à s'installer rapidement la
rémunération sera versée par
l'administration d'origine fut remboursé
par le médecin il s'agira donc d'une
opération neutre pour les finances de la
collectivité en plus d'être facultative
et temporaire le contrat pourrait
également prévoir que le remboursement
du salaire soit décalé dans le temps la
Commission a souhaité apporter certaines
limites bienvenue à ce nouvel outil en
prévoyant qu'il s'agit d'un dispositif
d'amorçage d'une durée maximale de neuf
mois et uniquement dans les cabines
libéraux récemment installés le tout
dans le cas d'une participation du
médecin à la permanence de soins
ambulatoire ces précisions et
contreparties devraient rassurer ceux
qui craignaient de voir l'argent public
se substituer durablement au personnel
que le médecin pourrait recruter
la question de la désertification
médicale inquiète les élus locaux et les
nombreuses initiatives ont déjà été
mises en place par les collectivités
pour améliorer l'accès aux soins les
collectivités sont d'ailleurs à
l'origine de 23% des centres de santé à
activité médicale cette proposition de
loi propose donc de donner des moyens
nouveaux et supplémentaires aux élus
pour agir en matière de santé en
s'attaquant de manière pragmatique à la
question de la charge administrative qui
est un réel problème elle viendra ainsi
compliquer les compléter les dispositifs
existants déployés par la CNAM et les
ARS elle viendra également en appui aux
efforts déjà déployés par les élus
locaux qui ne ménagent ni leur temps ni
leur énergie pour offrir un cadre de vie
attractif au médecin on le sait seule
une politique globale d'attractivité des
territoires permettra de mieux répartir
l'offre de soins en jouant sur l'emploi
le logement les transports même si nous
savons tous le nerf de la guerre demeure
le nombre de médecins formés cette PPL
apportera une réponse à certaines
collectivités qui peuvent aider leur
médecin salariés c'est le cas
aujourd'hui dans des maisons remonter et
ne peuvent pas même de manière
temporaire le faire pour des médecins
libéraux y compris quand les deux
statues coexistent dans le même lieu et
c'est un cas qu'on m'a rappelé très un
collègue d'ailleurs du Sénat j'entends
les points de vigilance à avoir dans ce
contexte de pénurie le risque de
concurrence entre les territoires et le
risque des phénomènes attaché à la
décentralisation convaincu que les
leviers d'actions sont sur les
territoires le groupe RDSE soutiendra
cette PPL certes ça a été dit elle ne
résoudra pas à elle seule la
désertification médicale mais elle
propose un outil supplémentaire
facultatif transitoire qui ne comporte
ni risques ni ne fait de perdants je
vous remercie merci chers collègues la
parole est à Madame Corinne Imbert pour
le groupe les républicains pour 3
minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires sociales monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues la
question de la désertification médicale
est une des thématiques qui revient ces
derniers mois très souvent au centre des
débats de la Haute Assemblée en plus
d'être une préoccupation majeure de nos
concitoyens elle est une préoccupation
majeure des sénatrices et sénateurs que
nous sommes l'ensemble des territoires
ruraux périurbains et urbains étant
confronté aujourd'hui à une démographie
médicale en baisse et donc un temps
médical devenu très précieux face à ce
constat alarmant les élus locaux de très
bonne volonté se retrouvent bien souvent
désemparés mais continue pourtant d'être
force de proposition afin de créer des
conditions nécessaires et favorables à
l'installation dans leur territoire de
professionnels de santé et plus
particulièrement de médecins
généralistes ce texte vient donc
s'ajouter au large panel de propositions
faites au sein de cette assemblée en
matière de lutte contre la
désertification médicale
cette proposition doit prévoit d'étendre
la mise à disposition de fonctionnaires
territoriaux au sein du cabinet médicaux
ou de maisons de santé ainsi cela
permettrait aux médecins souhaitant
s'installer dans des zones sous dotées
de ne pas avoir à s'occuper
temporairement du recrutement et de la
rémunération d'un personnel
administratif mais si nous comprenons
l'objectif de cette proposition de loi
pour répondre à quelques situations sa
mise en place nous laisse songeur même
avec cette proposition de loi amendée en
commission reconnaissons que
l'installation d'un médecin d'un médecin
généraliste par exemple de s'improvise
jamais qu'elle s'organise au contraire
plusieurs mois à l'avance et qu'à ce
titre le recrutement d'un personnel
administratif peut se réfléchir pendant
ce même temps avec bien sûr un
accompagnement de la collectivité avec
des recommandations possibles de la
commune quant à la recherche de
candidats potentiels sans que ceci soit
des agents de la collectivité bien sûr
nous avons entendu ce que vient de dire
notre collègue Véronique Guillotin entre
le statut de salarié ou de médecin
libéral exerçant dans une même structure
mais regarde du temps nécessaire et qui
est prévu pour prévoir son installation
mais semble que cette proposition de loi
n'est pas forcément pertinente et pour
cette raison le groupe les républicains
bien que sensible à l'objectif
rechercher votre a contre cette
proposition de loi je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Pierre de colle pour le
groupe les indépendants pour 5 minutes
madame la Présidente
monsieur le Président commission madame
la ministre se rapporteur mes chers
collègues
49 millions d'habitants
vivent dans un désert médical soit 72%
de la population française certes notre
population est vieillissante mais nous
avons formé moins de soignants
des experts aux pensées faire les
économies sur le système de santé tout
en gagnant en innovation et en
efficacité au contraire la gouvernance
c'est alourdi et à rigidifier beaucoup
de procédures un cloisonnement ville
hôpital s'est installé
les conséquences aussi sont bien connues
allongement des délais pour obtenir un
rendez-vous au risque d'une dégradation
de l'état de santé du patient des ports
de consultation vers les urgences
médicales difficultés pour le moins de
trouver un médecin traitant et donc
rupture du parcours et de la permanence
de soins pourtant garanti par la loi
si nous partageons ce constat nous
partageons également la responsabilité
de pallier ce problème certaines
réponses ont été apportées je pense
notamment à la création d'une quatrième
année d'internat de médecine générale
consacrée à des stages en cabinet
médical en priorité dans les zones
médicalement tendues cette proposition
initialement faite par le président
rotaïeu de bonaloa et attendu toutefois
il nous faut encore attendre les
premiers effets mes chers collègues
cette situation nous oblige à accueillir
toute initiative avec responsabilité il
n'est pas question de se priver d'outils
avérés utiles la proposition de loi
examinée aujourd'hui est un de ces
outils
ce texte proposé par notre collègue
Danny Walden comporte un article unique
permettant la mise à disposition d'agent
auprès de cabinet communaux et de
maisons de santé par les collectivités
territoriales
en début d'année lors de ces vœux aux
acteurs de santé le président de la
République a précisé je cite les
médecins généralistes doivent pouvoir se
concentrer sur la santé rien que sur la
santé cette proposition de loi pourrait
permettre d'aller vers cette ambition
toutefois il n'est pas question de
déléguer la gestion administrative du
cabinet médicaux aux collectivités
territoriales à cet égard je tiens à
saluer le travail du rapporteur le
docteur Daniel Chassin fort de sa
connaissance du monde médical en milieu
rural a su donner à cette proposition de
loi une orientation précise il faut
entendre ce texte comme l'ouverture
d'une possibilité pour les collectivités
territoriales volontaristes
il s'agit de leur donner la faculté de
mettre pendant une courte période soit
trois mois renouvelable deux fois un
agent à disposition d'un cabinet médical
ou d'une maison de santé le traitement
de l'agence aura naturellement remboursé
ultérieurement par la structure
d'accueil ce dispositif pourrait être
utilisé exclusivement lorsqu'un nouveau
médecin arrive et s'il exerce la mission
de service public de permanence de soins
ce dernier point est tout à fait
important la permanence de soins est au
fondement de notre réflexion dans la
lutte contre la désertification médicale
elle doit être la faire de toutes et de
tous les élus locaux souhaitent
légitimement pouvoir assurer cette
mission de service public sur leur
territoire nous devons les accompagner
dans cette direction vous le savez
je suis un ardent défenseur de
l'initiative parlementaire les
expériences sur le terrain en contact
direct avec les élus locaux et nos
concitoyens nous guident dans la
rédaction et la proposition d'évolution
législative ayant pour objectif de
répondre à des difficultés concrètes le
texte proposé par notre collègue Dani
water s'inscrit dans cet esprit
chers collègues avant de conclure je
voudrais relever les propos de certains
orateurs qui m'ont précédé à cette
tribune
lorsqu'il s'agissait de d'évoquer
les personnels des collectivités
territoriales quant à leur compétences
et le respect de la confidentialité
nous leur avons fait confiance quand il
s'est agi de mettre en place les agences
postales dans une situation similaire
nous lavons fait confiance pour soutenir
les actions lorsqu'il s'est agit de
lutter contre le covid les chers
collègues ne manquons pas l'occasion de
créer un nouveau levier pour lutter
contre la désasification médicale le
groupe Les Indépendants votre
naturellement pour cette proposition de
loi je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Madame Nadia solo pour le groupe Union
centriste pour 4 minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues l'accès aux soins
dans les territoires particulièrement
ruraux est un problème majeur dont vous
avez tous une conscience aiguë je ne
vous apprends rien face à cette
situation chaque élu qui soit locale ou
nationale cherche des solutions qui sont
parfois des propositions de réforme
structurelles et parfois simplement des
outils pratiques mais qui peuvent faire
la différence et permettre d'accueillir
de nouveaux soignants dans cet esprit
notre collègue Danny watte bled
peut-être inspiré par une situation
concrète ou par son expérience du
terrain nous fait une proposition
intéressante en s'inspirant des
partenariats qui ont pu être établis par
exemple entre les collectivités et la
Poste afin de garantir un maillage
territorial et une proximité pourquoi ne
pas mettre à disposition d'un cabinet
médical ou d'une maison de santé de
façon temporaire et remboursable un
agent communal les outils financiers
fiscaux aident de diverses natures déjà
en place sont nombreux et pourtant
n'arrive plus à déclencher chez les
hommes les jeunes praticiens la décision
d'installation et c'est une vraie
difficulté
ces étudiants en fin de cursus au moment
de franchir le grand pas vers l'exercice
en autonomie en indépendance et sous
leurs propres responsabilités sont
souvent angoissées par des questions
pratiques qui peuvent les amener à
reculer concrètement qui pour décrocher
le téléphone le premier jour connaître
la population locale le contexte social
éventuellement pouvoir indiquer les
lieux et les adresses des patients je me
souviens personnellement pour avoir
accueilli sur ma commune nivernaise un
nouveau médecin arrivant de Belgique de
l'aide précieuses et bénévoles de mon
adjoint alors facteurs retraités qui
accompagnaient bénévolement le médecin
dans ses premières tournées et du même
médecin belge qui les premières semaines
n'ayant pas pu s'occuper de recruter une
collaboratrice et ne connaissant
personne de confiance décrocher lui-même
le téléphone c'est qu'il lui faisait
perdre beaucoup de temps lorsqu'un
médecin arrive dans une commune
particulièrement rural l'équipe
municipale au sens large fait un
véritable service d'accompagnement dans
les premières semaines et c'est une des
conditions l'installation réussie dès
lors permettent la mise à disposition
d'un agent public d'accueil connaissant
un territoire et ses habitants afin de
faire un lien aider à la prise de
contact pendant une période d'amorçage
me semble un outil intéressant et même
assez évident les soucis d'ordre
pratique font partie des critères
poussant les candidats à l'installation
vers le salariat plutôt que vers
l'exercice libéral et il nous le disent
ils apprécient au moins dans les
premiers temps d'être épaulé et déchargé
de certaines contingences matérielles
évidemment cette facilité ne réglera pas
malgré son titre prometteur nos
problèmes dramatiques de désertification
médicale il faudrait pour cela bien
d'autres outils et il faudrait surtout
beaucoup plus de médecins un plan massif
de formation les médecins désormais sont
tellement rares la pression est devenue
telle sur les épaules des étudiants en
fin de cursus qui sont écrasés par les
demandes les attentes les offres la
responsabilité on leur offre des primes
des surprises des avantages matériels et
dans le même temps l'insécuries ont les
terrorise on les fait fuir ce n'est pas
un formant 15% de médecins en plus qu'on
sortira de cette surenchère malsaine et
contre-productive il faut des outils
sécurisants mais surtout une vraie
décision politique qui n'a pas encore
été prise les jeunes Français vont
toujours apprendre la médecine en
Roumanie ou en Espagne vous aurez
compris que cet outil est un outil de
plus et nous y sommes favorables en
l'occurrence qui peut le plus peu moins
j'espère seulement que maison de santé
sera entendu au sens large avec ou sans
médecin car il est évident que tous les
autres professionnels de santé nous sont
également précieux infirmiers dentistes
qui née pharmacien et il devrait pouvoir
bénéficier des mêmes facilités je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Claude Anglard pour le
groupe les républicains pour 4 minutes
madame merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues
la proposition de loi tente d'apporter
une nouvelle solution à la
désertification médicale sujet déjà
traitée à travers les PLFSS et d'autres
propositions de loi ces derniers mois
comme celles adopté le 18 octobre 2022
visant à la consolidation et à la
professionnalisation de la formation des
internes en médecine générale
les constats de la désertification
médicale ont déjà été longuement abordés
dans cette mystique le texte que nous
examinons aujourd'hui propose
d'autoriser la mise à disposition de
fonctionnaires territoriaux auprès de
cabinets médicaux ou de maisons de santé
comme leur rappeler tous mes collègues
la possibilité pour les collectivités de
mettre à disposition temporairement en
agent public serait un nouveau levier
d'attractivité médicale pour le
territoire en allégeant les contraintes
financières et administratives qui
pèsent sur l'installation des médecins
il s'agirait de l'accompagnement sur
toute la durée de l'installation de
médecins en zone soudance le
fonctionnaire territorial pourrait
éventuellement être chargé de l'accueil
de la patientèle
si cette solution est louable et vise
évidemment à favoriser l'implantation de
médecins dans les déserts médicaux les
moyens choisis interrogent
malgré les améliorations apportées par
le rapporteur Daniel Chassin pour
clarifier le caractère transitoire et
temporaire du dispositif celui-ci
appelle des réserves
en effet le recours ressources humaines
d'une collectivité locale pour la
gestion d'un secrétariat médical soulève
de nombreuses interrogations sur la
formation professionnelle et les risques
d'incompatibilité avec le statut du
fonctionnaire les filières et cadres
d'emploi
la proposition de loi ne traite pas la
nature des missions qui pourraient être
confiée au fonctionnaire territorial
qu'il s'agisse de la responsabilité
juridique de l'employeur et de la
garantie du secret médical le dispositif
proposé ne paraît pas une
opérationnalité optimale
j'ajoute à cela les réserves émises par
les associations d'élus locaux lors de
leurs auditions sur les difficultés de
recrutement rencontrées par les
collectivités sur les métiers
susceptibles d'être concernés par la
mise à disposition sur le risque de
doublon avec d'autres dispositions
existantes notamment les fonctions
d'assistant médicaux ou encore
la formation des personnels mise à
disposition et les besoins du cabinet
médicaux et sous les effets pervers de
concurrence entre les collectivités
pour l'attractivité médicale outre ses
réserves j'attire aussi votre attention
sur les solutions existantes je rappelle
par exemple nous avons amélioré
simplifié et renforcer la coordination
de l'installation des professionnels de
santé en harmonisation à l'harmonisant
pardon le dispositif d'aide à
l'installation dans l'article 24 du
PLFSS de 2023 de plus les expériences
locales peuvent être source d'aspiration
j'évoquerai en ce sens rapidement la
politique d'attractivité expérimenté en
Aveyron depuis 2010 pour inciter les
médecins de médecine générale à
s'installer
l'implication des médecins en exercice
et du conseil de l'ordre des médecins a
été crucial dans la définition d'une
politique d'attractivité médicale qui a
emporté des ses débuts l'adhésion de
l'ARS aborder la désertification
médicale recommande une approche globale
et partagée à l'échelle de nos
territoire la stratégie repose sur un
accompagnement de la profession d'abord
en favorisant l'accueil des stagiaires
par la promotion des terrains de stage
par l'intégration des stagiaires et
l'aide financière aux transports et au
logement des internes éloignés de leur
résidence ensuite en soutenant les
réalisations de maisons de santé
professionnelle adossé un projet de
santé enfin en créant un guichet unique
d'accompagnement à l'installation le
succès repose sur une coordination
inédite tous les acteurs et la cellule
accueille installation c'est imposée
progressivement comme un interlocuteur
privilégié elle réunit dans une approche
partenariale volontariste réformée
d'accord excusez-moi donc je voulais
dire que depuis 2011 nous n'avons il y a
eu 105 installations de médecins
généralistes pour 107 départ et au vu de
ces éléments on émet un bébé très
réservé à cette proposition de loi
la parole est à Madame Nadine bellurault
pour le groupe les républicains pour 3
minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le Président des commissions
des affaires sociales monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues ce texte
propose un nouvel outil à la disposition
des collectivités territoriales comme
cela a été dit précédemment la rédaction
issue des travaux de la commission avec
son article unique répond aux
inquiétudes soulevées par celle-ci à ce
sujet concernant la concurrence que l'on
pourrait constater entre les communes
dire qu'elle existe déjà les
collectivités territoriales elles
financent les installations elle donne
des des aides notamment par exemple dans
le département de l'Inde c'est 30000
euros tout ça se conjugue avec des aides
nationales comme les aiderrai et
n'oublions pas notamment que les
collectivités financent aussi des
maisons de santé et comme je le dis
souvent le parpaing ne fait pas le
médecin et l'AS
ce texte vient donc aider temporairement
à l'installation d'un médecin en
permettant d'ouvrir aux maisons de santé
et cabinet libéraux en zone soudance le
bénéfice de la mise à disposition de
fonctionnaires territoriaux agents
territoriaux qui peuvent connaître en
effet leur territoire et leurs habitants
ils pourront ainsi accompagner dans la
gestion au quotidien ce cabinet les
médecins manquent partout en France
madame la ministre certes vous n'êtes
pas responsable des mauvaises décisions
prises par les précédents gouvernement
et relatives à la formation des médecins
en revanche vous êtes responsable du bon
fonctionnement du Conseil national de
gestion qui disons le franchement est un
outil qui ne fonctionne absolument pas
de par son opacité aucune information
son inefficacité dans la gestion des
dossiers des commissions de se
réunissent que très rarement le CNG
bloque la possibilité pour des milliers
de médecins français ou étrangers ayant
des diplômes certes hors Union
Européenne de s'installer s'il le
souhaite dans les territoires notamment
ruraux et c'est le cas entre octobre
2020 et octobre 2021 c'est 4500 dossiers
déposés auprès des ARS pour validation
par le CNG après un parcours de
consolidation de une à deux années main
d'oeuvre peu cher dans les hôpitaux
seulement quelques centaines de dossiers
avaient reçu un avis favorable du CNG en
début d'année 2022 des années d'attentes
pour ces professionnels du droit des
examens au compte-goutte pour très peu
de validation je connais de nombreux cas
madame la ministre il y a urgence dans
toutes les spécialités nos territoires
se meurent car les Français ne sont pas
soignés aujourd'hui en France pallier
donc au manque d'organisation et de
disponibilité des ARS et des jurys du
CNG manquent d'ailleurs reconnu dans
cette hémicycle par votre prédécesseur
peut-être faudrait-il abandonner
totalement ce système qui d'ailleurs
n'avait pas été retenu
par le ministre de l'Intérieur dans le
texte immigration pour la carte de
séjour talents professions médicales et
de la pharmacie et que ce soit
l'administration centrale de votre
ministère qui prennent à nouveau puisque
tel fut le cas en charge toutes ces
demandes d'homologation dont les
médecins professionnels de santé ont
besoin et la France aussi je vous
remercie merci chers collègues la parole
est à Monsieur Cyril pelvat pour le
groupe les républicains pour 4 minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues il va sans dire que chacun ici
présent mesure l'impact de la
désertification médicale pour nos
concitoyens et ainsi d'Amand pour nos
collectivités les conséquences sont
nombreuses
urgences débordées renoncement aux soins
et donc dégradation de l'état médical ou
encore rupture du parcours de soins
désormais 72% ça déjà été dire de la
population habite dans une zone
caractérisée par une offre de soins
insuffisante ou par des difficultés dans
l'accès aux soins et 12% dans un désert
médical à proprement parler dans mon
département de la Haute-Savoie le
phénomène est amplifié du fait de sa
proximité avec la Suisse qui entraîne
une hausse du coût de la vie
décourageant les professionnels de santé
de s'y installer mais aussi une fuite
chez nos voisins helvétiques
certaines communes désespèrent de
trouver des médecins et pas plus tard
que la semaine dernière j'ai remarqué
que l'une d'entre elles en étaient même
venu installer des panneaux à l'entrée
du village indiquant qu'elle cherchait
désespérément un généraliste le problème
de fond est celui du manque de médecin
il est désormais identifié des mesures
ont été prises au niveau national pour y
aller tel que la fin du numérique mais
les effets ne sont tangibles ne seront
tangibles que d'ici quelques années et
dans l'attente je suis plutôt favorable
à ce que nous prévoyons des dispositifs
complémentaires en particulier s'ils
offrent de nouveaux leviers aux
collectivités qui souhaiteraient être
volontariste à ce sujet nombre dentelles
ne sont malgré le peu d'outils à leur
disposition
en créant des maisons de santé en
mettant à disposition des locaux et en
offrant des aides financières aux
nouveaux médecins s'installant il faut
les féliciter mais aussi il faut faire
gaffe attention à une certaine
surenchère de certaines de certains
professionnels
j'accueille donc plutôt positivement la
proposition de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui et qui vise à permettre aux
collectivités de mettre à disposition de
cabinets médicaux et de maisons de santé
des fonctionnaires territoriaux dans les
zones soudances celle-ci permettra
d'ajouter une corde à l'arc des
collectivités et va dans le sens de la
décentralisation et de la confiance en
nos élus locaux pour être force de
proposition les modifications adoptées
par la commission me semble bienvenu on
sait qu'ils viennent border le
dispositif dans le but d'en faire une
aide temporaire à l'installation de
nouveaux médecins qui pourraient y avoir
recours pour avoir un appui
administratif ou pas la coordination
avec d'autres professionnels de santé du
territoire de même l'ajout du
conditionnement de la mise à disposition
à une participation à la permanence de
soins ambulatoires permet de clarifier
le lien avec le service public
nécessaire à toute mise à disposition
le fait qu'il s'agisse d'une simple
faculté et qu'il n'y ait pas d'impact
financier pour la collectivité puisque
les salaires devraient être remboursés
entraîne une souplesse qui pourrait être
appréciée par les médecins comme les
collectivités par ailleurs la crainte
d'une concurrence entre commune me
paraît incondies puisque dispositif est
temporaire et interviendrait qu'une fois
que le médecin a pris sa décision de
s'installer je voterai donc en faveur de
ce texte ma seule réserve étant que
puisque les collectivités ont déjà du
mal à recruter il est nécessaire que sa
mise en œuvre aille de pair avec un
travail sur l'attractivité de la
fonction publique enfin avant de
conclure je tiens seulement à insister
sur le fait que la mise en place
d'outils à destination des collectivités
pour participer à la lutte contre les
déserts médicaux ne doit en revanche pas
conduire l'État se dédouaner de sa
responsabilité c'est à lui que revient
au premier lieu le rôle de trouver des
solutions et beaucoup restent encore à
faire pour clore ce chapitre cela
passera nécessairement par une
différenciation en fonction des
spécificités des territoires comme par
exemple pour mon département la mise en
place d'établissements de santé et de
formation transfrontaliers une meilleure
prise en charge des soins effectués dans
d'autres dans d'autres pays ou encore
une prise en charge des frais de
scolarité des personnels de santé en
contrepartie d'un engagement exercé un
certain nombre d'années en France je
suis d'ailleurs madame la ministre à
votre entière disposition pour échanger
sur ses propositions je vous remercie
merci chers collègues alors la parole
est à Monsieur Dominique Théophile pour
le groupe rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants pour 6
minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues comme vous le savez cela fait
plusieurs années que j'interviens dans
cette émission pour aller acheter sur le
sujet de la
désertification médicale notamment dans
les territoires d'outre-mer ou la
densité de médecin est très inférieure à
la moyenne nationale je vais débuter mon
intervention par une vraie illustration
que ma collègue victoire jasmin connaît
bien l'année dernière en Guadeloupe
l'île de La Désirade souffrait de
l'absence totale de médecins aujourd'hui
malgré l'ouverture récente d'un centre
de santé et la présence quelques jours
par semaine de médecin l'offre de soins
et demeure très insuffisante et la
population en compte une forte
difficulté d'accès ce territoire souffre
en effet de sa double insularité des
difficultés d'accès tout comme chez nous
Désirade les Center de Battles
classée au quatrième rang des régions
françaises ayant les densités de
médecins généralistes libéraux les plus
faibles la Guadeloupe est donc bien un
véritable désert médical
nous misons beaucoup cependant sur les
maisons de santé qui se développent dans
les communes pour attirer fidéliser les
médecins mais également dans les
prochaines années sur les premiers
résultats de la Faculté de médecine de
plein d'exercice aux Antilles je tiens à
saluer le rapport réalisé par nos
collègues Patricia gillanget et Philippe
mouiller en octobre 2021 qui préconise
de bâtir des centres ou maison de santé
partenariaux en étroite concertation
avec les élus locaux et les
professionnels de santé ainsi que le
renforcement des liens entre les
collectivités territoriales et les
facultés de médecine la proposition de
la loi que nous examinons aujourd'hui
dans le cadre de la journée réservée au
groupe Les Indépendants s'inscrit dans
cette dynamique en permettant d'élargir
la liste des entités susceptibles
d'accueillir un agent public au cabinet
médical ainsi comme maison de santé cet
article renforcera la boîte à outils à
la disposition des acteurs locaux pour
agir concrètement sur l'accès aux soins
si nous émettions quelques réticences en
commission nous saluons la réécriture
globale de l'article unique sur la
proposition du rapporteur qui permet
d'établir un équilibre en encadrant la
durée de recours potentiels au
dispositif et en leur conditionnant une
installation récente des médecins
exercants en cabinet libéral le
dispositif en effet pour principal
vocation d'accompagner les médecins à
leur arrivée pour les inciter à
s'installer sur un nouveau territoire il
faudra toutefois être vigilant sur la
création de concurrence entre les
territoires en effet il pourrait y avoir
un risque que certains territoires
multiplient les dispositifs incitatifs
quand d'autres ne pourront rien proposer
par manque de moyens il ne faudrait pas
que la multiplication des dispositifs
sans vision systémique et globale
entraîne une nouvelle hiérarchisation
locale cependant malgré ce point notre
groupe du Rassemblement démocrate
progressistes et indépendant votre en
faveur de cette proposition de loi car
tout dispositif qui vise à augmenter les
leviers d'action pour répondre à l'une
des attentes les plus principales de nos
concitoyens doit être encouragé je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues alors là Monsieur
Chassin
[Musique]
merci Madame madame la Présidente donc
je voudrais dire un mot sur ce qu'a dit
par exemple Annie Annie lorrault
loue ou excusez-moi donc si vous voulez
ce qui a été proposé dans cette PPL si
vous laissez ponctuel
formation médicale on ne demande pas du
tout bien sûr les médecins spécialistes
ont besoin de quelqu'un qui a une
formation médicale avec les termes
médicaux mais là on me demande pas ça
c'est simplement quelqu'un qui prendrait
des appels
en plus de d'avoir si vous voulez une
plateforme qui accueillerait la
clientèle la patientèle qui pourrait
renseigner le médecin qui arrive s'il a
des visites à faire dans le territoire
il connaît pas le territoire si c'est
notamment un médecin étranger et ça
c'est complètement ponctuel et surtout
alors j'ai dit une coordination c'est
entre guillemets mais c'est surtout vous
savez que un médecin il est en fait le
chef d'orchestre un peu dans la maison
de santé et il va avoir des documents
qui lui seront demandés par les par les
phares par les pharmaciens quelques fois
mais surtout par les infirmiers par le
kiné par les orthophonistes par la
pédicure c'est des certificats à
renouveler si vous voulez et on n'est
pas toujours la disponible pour
rencontrer ces paramédicaux et donc il y
a quelqu'un qui va collationner en ce
qui concerne madame Cohen bien sûr le
numérique russe clausus et oui je
voulais rajouter aussi là c'est pts vous
avez parlé de la CTS mais là c'est pts
il faut avoir un médecin pour les pour
pouvoir participer à la CPTs s'il y a
pas de médecin on parle pas de CPTs en
ce qui concerne madame Cohen bon le
numerus clausus portera ses fruits en
2030 effectivement il aurait fallu faire
une humérus clausus beaucoup plus tôt je
voudrais remercier
Jocelyne Jocelyne guidez
bon en ce qui concerne le secret médical
les personnes qui sont dans une commune
savent aussi pour avoir secret aussi et
Véronique Guillotin je la remercie parce
que ça elle a exprimé
des sentiments si vous voulez de
médecins de terrain ainsi qu'aucine
Corinne Imbert bien sûr une une
installation
se décide des mois avant mais je voulais
vous dire que
médecin étranger malheureusement tout le
monde n'a pas eu le travail qu'a fait en
amont l'Aveyron que je salue mais des
médecins étrangers qui arrivent il va
arriver il faut un logement et puis une
connaît pas du tout le secteur donc
c'est pour cela je répète c'est très
ponctuel merci à Nadia Sokoluk qui a
aussi une élue rurale
aussi remercier de notre collègue de
l'Aveyron mais je voudrais lui dire que
c'est pas un doublon quand il y a un
assistant médical qui arrive ou une
secrétaire mais on s'en va bien sûr
c'est uniquement en avant très de façon
très ponctuelle
enfin Nadine
c'est ce que vous avez dit c'est une
disposition ponctuelle et je suis
d'accord avec ce qui a été ce qu'elle a
dit sur le l'homologation
Cyril pelvin effectivement c'est un
nouveau levier c'est une confiance aux
élus locaux et pour la permanence ce que
on a rajouté la commission m'a suivi
rajouter effectivement la permanence des
soins ambulatoire le médecin doit
s'engager à la permanence des soins
obligatoires et je remercie aussi
Dominique Théophile il n'y a pas de
concurrence entre les communes et les
territoires car il y a car il y a un
remboursement obligatoire merci
monsieur le rapporteur donc la
discussion générale est close nous
allons passer à la discussion du texte
de la commission nous avons un
amendement du Gouvernement même la
ministre vous avez la parole pour le
défendre
merci madame la Présidente donc cet
amendement propose une réécriture
globale de l'article unique de la
proposition de loi notamment ont
clarifiant la rédaction en permettant
aux fonctionnaires des trois versants de
la fonction publique de participer au
dispositif comme je l'ai dit lors de la
discussion générale le gouvernement à
mettre un avis positif sur cette
proposition de loi qui comme ça a été
dit par certains d'entre vous apporte
une réponse ça n'est pas une révolution
nous souhaitons apporter des réponses
pragmatiques le vote de cette
proposition loi apporte une réponse
pragmatique il n'y a pas d'obligation
nous sommes dans le facultatif il n'y a
pas de moyens financiers publiques mis
par les collectivités territoriales il
s'agit d'une avance et je le redis ça
n'est pas une obligation c'est vraiment
du facultatif j'entends les messages
envoyés par les associations des élus
la difficulté de recruter même des
secrétaires des secrétaires dans la
mairie mais je le dis les médecins les
médecins qui ont besoin qui veulent
s'installer on doit pouvoir faciliter
leur installation et quand on arrive
dans un territoire qu'on ne connaît pas
Madame Imbert parfois on peut juste
avoir besoin pendant trois mois de
quelqu'un qui nous fasse connaître le
territoire qui nous fasse découvrir le
territoire qui prennent en charge le
temps de d'embaucher quelqu'un donc
c'est évident c'est de permettre de
lever les freins à l'installation ça
n'est pas une révolution nous en sommes
tous très clair c'est juste une
proposition pragmatique que nous
souhaitons accompagner
merci Madame la vie de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
la présidente effectivement
contrairement à ce que la rédaction et
son objet pourraient laisser penser cet
amendement de modification que
partiellement très partiellement le
dispositif adopté la semaine dernière au
passé par la commission des affaires
sociales je constate que le gouvernement
a conservé les modifications apportées à
mon initiative visant à clarifier le
dispositif à le limiter aux organismes
participants effectivement à une mission
de service public est le conditionner à
une installation récente de
professionnels libéraux ou encore
encadrer le temps dans le temps sont
recours le seul objet du présent
amendement est ainsi d'ouvrir la mise à
disposition des fonctionnaires auprès de
cabinets médicaux de maison de santé en
zone soudain
au 3 versants de la fonction publique et
non plus à la seule fonction publique
territoriale bon à titre personnel moi
je ne voyais que des avantages à cet
amendement d'une part cette amendement
donnerait au dispositifs une ampleur
supplémentaires lui permettant de
répondre avec plus d'effectivité à son
objectif lutter contre la
désertifications médicales et d'autre
part cet amendement montre bien que la
lutte contre la désertification médicale
n'est pas
n'est pas à la seule charge des
collectivités territoriales mais bien
une responsabilité partagée donc la
Commission a émis des réserves sur ce
dispositif notamment eugar aux
difficultés de recrutement rencontrés
par les employeurs hospitaliers qui
limiteraient la portée de la maman
proposée donc je donne la vie de la
commission qui est défavorable merci
[Musique]
alors je vais mettre au voile
l'amendement de rédaction globale de
l'article unique constituant l'ensemble
de la proposition de loi l'adoption de
cet amendement vaudrait adoption de
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi ce
qui a des demandes d'explications de
vote
même jasmin
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre la proposition quand on regarde
bien lutter contre la désertification
médicale et bien nous sommes tous
favorables cependant pour les
collectivités l'ensemble des
collectivités on voit bien qu'il y a des
problèmes il y a des problèmes et
l'association des mers ruraux ainsi que
des départements de France et aussi la
cette proposition et nous qui sommes les
représentants des collectivités nous
pouvons pas accepter n'importe quoi
pourquoi dans mon territoire et
particulièrement dans l'ensemble des
territoires d'outre-mer et bien il y a
de plus en plus de recours au contraire
de redressement notamment notre mère les
corums sont sur les collectivités
demandent des couronnes justement parce
qu'ils ont les problèmes budgétaires
donc on ne peut pas être incohérent à ce
point donc là je vous fréquente et mon
groupe de toute façon avait déjà dit que
d'aller voter contre il y a d'autres
possibilités
faisons en sorte que nous puissions
réfléchir pour avoir quelque chose de
cohérent de pertinent et déficience mais
pas du bricolage alors c'est une
proposition qui est volontaire mais on
ne peut pas non plus s'accepter
n'importe quoi donc j'ai entendu
l'ensemble des collègues et je crois que
nous devons réfléchir pour trouver des
meilleures solutions possibles pour
éviter le pied dans nos territoires
c'est vrai mais nous ne pouvons pas
accepter une telle proposition contenue
la situation dans nos collectivités
merci merci Monsieur Wathelet
présidente moi personnellement au titre
de de cette ouverture sur trois versant
je suis favorable puisque ça ça conforte
la prof de loi puisqu'elle s'ouvre à
plusieurs versants et je pense que de
mettre à disposition du personnel qu'il
soit territorial médical ou d'état c'est
qu'un plus et c'est toujours au choix
donc je voudrais favorablement
la parole
répétez si vous voulez qu'il y a pas de
concurrence entre les communes qu'il n'y
a si vous voulez financièrement ce sera
complètement neutre puisque vous le
savez très bien que il n'est pas
possible de
qui est un agent public qui aille
travailler dans un cabinet médical ou
dans une maison de santé il faut que y
ait obligatoirement un remboursement
donc il n'y a pas de concurrence entre
les communes merci
merci alors je vais mettre au voie donc
l'amendement de rédaction globale de
l'article unique constitue en l'ensemble
de la proposition de loi relatives aux
outils de lutte contre la
désertification médicale des
collectivités et pour ce vote j'ai été
saisi par une demande de scrutin public
et je vous rappelle que la vie de la
commission est défavorable et la vie du
Gouvernement est favorable
les indépendants pardon
du groupe Les Indépendants
il va être procédé donc au scrutin
public dans les conditions fixées par
l'article 56 du règlement le scrutin est
ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
résultat du scrutin nombre de votants
343 exprimer 341 pour 109 contre 232 le
Sénat n'a pas adopté l'amendement alors
je vais mettre au voile article unique
constituant l'ensemble de la proposition
de loi le vote donc sur l'article voudra
vote sur l'ensemble de la proposition de
loi ce qu'il y a des demandes
d'explication de vote
non je n'en vois pas
j'étais saisie d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe les indépendants
sur l'ensemble de la proposition de loi
va être procédé au scrutin public dans
les conditions fixées par l'article 56
du règlement le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
résultat du scrutin nombre de votants
343 exprimer 343 pour 108 contre 235 le
Sénat n'a pas adopté cette proposition
de loi
alors mes chers collègues je vais je
vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 16h pour l'examen de la
proposition de loi visant à permettre
une gestion différenciée de la
compétence haut et assainissement la
séance est suspendue